as a human for every click of a button
that you have in your test which is
thousands you can't remember oh wait a
second
i use this property but this is i'm
going to change it so i need to
you can't remember all the things for a
computer
that's like
[Music]
alvin loping thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders it's
been a while but i'm so glad that i
finally caught you how are you
indeed doing great my friend how about
you doing fantastic you were so kind and
gracious to invite me to a wonderful
dinner
a few months ago i don't know if you
remember but you brought us you brought
a great focus group
we talked about testing we talked about
research and development
and we talked about the struggles of
building beautiful
products and it was very inspiring for
me so thank you for the invitation for
that
uh you're welcome my friend any chance
to see is great i love it
oren you have a beautiful journey from
ibm
to wix to apple tools to now testimo
with a lot of things in between that i
didn't even mention and
but it doesn't do justice to to the core
of your journey
tell me a little bit about yourself and
how do you even get involved with
with testing well first of all
notice that it goes from bigger
companies to smaller like ibm's 300
i was employed 330 uh cadence that was
completely number five thousand
uh wix that was 151
uh appleton that was employee number one
and with testing that's
employee number zero yeah wow okay so
that's a beautiful funnel and slowly
through that funnel you're getting
closer and closer
to to this idea of quality and
architecture right i i think
i think quality was always there in this
in in the
around me like for example at ibm things
needs to be tested
i love doing that and actually making
shows when you as an
engineer you want to deliver a product
you want to make sure that it's high
quality of course you want to with
and also helping with the tools um as a
young engineer it's like
i love those actually so later with
cadence
um i was a compiler engineer there's a
there's a
there's a language there's two languages
that was developed in israel
so i was i was it was glad to be working
on one of them
but the nice part is it was a it was a
language for hollywood verification
uh so that means uh my users as
they say uh were people that are testing
so
to understand what they're doing you
need to understand a little bit about
testosterone
test automation or in this case how to
do an automation
so i always had this thing in the
background and even then
i went to weeks uh of course i did some
side projects and that's how wix got to
me and said hey we're moving from
this spring from flash to html come and
help us build this product
um and everything was tested manually it
says account as a person that came that
saw that everything was tested
automatically and even had a special
special language for that i was like
what no no no way we will
are we going at weeks manually so then
you start pushing in a company
which a company already has few hundred
people it's like uh
it's not that simple to make the change
uh but luckily you're amazing founders
uh
and i worked closely with uh anna
davrami and yo ava vrami
the more on the technical side i was uh
uh everyone
didn't get that i'm an engineer uh that
turned into the dark side
uh of product and business but um
but back then in weeks i saw the
challenge already and
and um and how to change a company and
how to make it from
only manual testing for to be full ci cd
what was the most difficult journey of
taking a company of a few hundred
developers
you know hundreds of thousands or
potentially millions lines of code and
not slowly transitioning to automatic
testing i know how difficult it is to do
it
when you have zero lines of code but how
difficult is it to do when you have a
lot of lines of code
so so i think in weeks it was a little
bit easier because they were just
building a new product
so that made it easier but you need to
convince people of actually that
right the way of cooking should be
different and you need to
find out who are the people that can
move something inside an organization
it's always like that that it's whether
that's uh in
in the technical side or not but you
need to understand who are kind of the
champions
who are the people that you need to get
them excited one by one get them excited
and eventually you'll have you'll have
the majority of people that
are that are rooting for that and will
start pushing toward that
and we'll make the change okay so i have
a challenge for you are you ready
i want you i want you to get me excited
about
testing
[Laughter]
basically because where you work you
already use testing are you testing
about wait a second are you talking
about test automation
or test team. let's start with this idea
of
why testing is even important
well you always test you don't even know
about it but you always test the
question is when
the question is who's testing it are you
testing it or your users
but yeah so bugs hurt your business and
it depends on the company
that it hurts you in a different way and
some bugs like
uh like uh intel had that costed four
billion dollars and the branding right
wow i remember that
oh yeah i'm not to mention uh spaceships
that that exploded dude
it's very it's critical to make sure
that you're testing
um you're making sure that your product
does exactly what you want
so some companies very few like netflix
can say wait a second
if something doesn't work you'll come
back uh in 30 minutes
but in a lot of cases think about the
weeks that someone wants to pay now
or paypal or anyone that wants to pay
something for a product if it doesn't
doesn't work
for the next 30 minutes they'll go to
the competition
right so you lose money so okay
i'm convinced the testing is important
but you know when i started
and my first uh my first few days as a
software engineer i was told
that before i deploy my product i need
to write a bunch of manual tests on jira
follow them manually and that's enough
then i'll deploy
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
ideology that i'll just write some
manual tests i'll repeat them every
deployment
and there's nobody better than my own
two eyes right
so i think there's a few things that
that actually happened in the last
decade
um one is that you you find out that
the earlier you find a bug the
cheaper it is to fix it so if you find
it just before production or a month
earlier
then it would it would that's a great uh
improvement
and roi so that's one thing the second
thing is
you actually manually you can't you
can't you don't have enough people in
the world
i just say you're you're we both there's
100 developers
if you want to write run your tests
before every pull request and there's a
lot of those
um and you'll need thousands of manual
people manual testers that will go and
click on stuff and you can't do that
if you want to first of all if you want
to uh go
with with the paradigm which is called
shift left you need a lot of you need a
lot of tests
and that means partialization and then i
will get there's environment
you want to run different houses
different parameters
there's not enough humans in the world
uh and that's why we go to
machines so and they do it much less
much better and you're gonna miss some
stuff
and the machine is not going to miss
that right even without coffee
i have to say that one of the first time
that i used the snapshot testing
it was still back in the in the idf and
i remembered that
i was developing this website and and i
ran my manual tests and everything
seemed good and i
had just started playing around with
with taking the snapshots
and through just i believe and and all
of a sudden
it showed me that that a part of the
website i didn't even notice
started shifting and and i could only
imagine
how this could roll and this bug would
continue and cost me more and more
or in i but i have to ask before we get
to test mio
you go through these companies you you
do all sorts of different technologies
and at the end you decide that you're
passionate about
automatic testing and helping
organizations around the world
to a better test and do it in a more fun
and scalable way
why do you focus on that why is that the
passion at the end
i think that it actually started with
the second thing of what you said
which is i wanted to help and say
uh i love and so are you your life you
we love help to help people and but now
we need to understand
how can i help and what is the best
thing that i can do to help people
and of course to affect much as much as
more
as possible because if you if you work
for one one company you help them if you
work at a company
but if you deliver a product that can
help
thousands of companies then you get you
you feel
uh you can help the large scale of the
world
so it starts with that the fact that you
want to help
and the fact that you need to understand
what can i do
uh what can i do best and i think
when i asked about different questions i
would talk to before starting
testing i talked to so many vp engineers
in israel uh in the world and in israel
it's more was much easier because
everyone
is like in a walking distance yeah or
now the
zoom distance um but you find out
where's that where are those challenges
what are their pains that's the most
important
thing and it's weird that a lot of i
know a lot of engineers go to the
the dog side of the business and we can
start a startup
the most important thing they need to
remember that's
someone that someone taught me a few
years ago
you start the conversation not about
explaining what your product does
is explaining what is the pain of the
other person you never and everyone
keeps saying things that
uh salespeople are sleazy and like no it
doesn't supposed to be like that
have a product that answers someone's
pain they'll want to buy it
but usually a salesperson sometimes they
have
struggled to buy it the salesperson is
just
navigate that and make sure that they're
going to make it in the most easiest way
it all starts with hey you're selling
you're
uh you're solving a real challenge so
how long did that take so so you entered
the startup phase very convinced that
you're solving a deep problem you've
experienced it yourself
you're talking to a bunch of vp
engineers you're doing your research
what is the solution that you come up
with that could solve
this this problem for a lot of people
um i saw that most people
didn't even get started with test engine
automation
and there i have noticed trends first of
all there's actually a trend
there's one that code is moving to the
front end
like every 10 years code is moving from
the back into the front and it was
mainframes then that's the back end then
it was personal pcs the code was in the
front end
then the web came along and the servers
and the code again was
a lot of the most of the code was in the
backend now we noticed
react angular apps there's like so many
of the code
business critical business logic was
moving to the front end and nobody knew
how to test it
so everyone i see that there's a channel
everyone says wait a second
i used to have one line of call in the
front end which i tested manually
now i have a million of those how the
hell do i test it
right and of course test end to end so
we saw uh uh the trend first of all you
see a trend
and you're saying hey it's going to
spike the testing on the front end
is uh is gonna is gonna trend
and what are the existing tools and
existing tools
if you think about that uh just
understanding a megabyte
20-15 years ago last time the front-end
was in the center
uh it was so much uh information
like one one gigabyte it was like oh my
god it's so huge we
the method things like ai didn't exist
20 years ago like
think of the change that's been since
and then you're thinking
uh what what has changed and how can i
use technology to actually solve
something
that that's needed so you start with
that
so you start with that and so what is
what what is
the product now that you've been working
on for the past few years that i've also
had a pleasure of playing around with
quite a few times um
so we and what we saw we said wait a
second to
help with end-to-end testing we said one
of the biggest challenges
was that the ui keeps changing all the
time
and the current all the current
technologies use
one property you have to say hey find
this button based on
i don't know the text you have to first
you have to name it you have to do it
yourself
and that's literally i could do it
calling it like almost like doing it
manually
um and the second thing is that it
changes the application keeps changing
but but you can as a human for every
click of a button that you have in your
test which is
thousands you can't remember
wait a second i use this property but
this is i'm going to change it so i
needed
you can't remember all those things for
a computer
that's like that's like no-brainer they
can follow and for every click you can
have
thousands of different attributes uh and
features and you can say
oh i can find it in more ways than a
human
things that a human didn't even think
about i can think of a
ways to argue find that element so in in
here specifically
uh we we took the pain that people had
which is
how do i test faster right i want to
release tomorrow why do i need to
write a test for a week i need it in
five minutes and the challenge of
in that case it's uh it's called
testability or test flakiness
and taking those challenges and saying
hey how can i have a
uh a solution that's that solves those
questions
right and that's so and that solution
becomes
a test mio and based out of san
francisco
that's yeah that's the beginning after
that you see
why people come to you and you talk to
you talk the more customers you have
you understand what exactly they want
you see more challenges
and and then you started seeing hey i
can do more things
i can help them i then they started
saying hey there's duplications
everywhere how can i find out and then
you're saying
oh we can use the same technology to
find all the duplications or recommend
you how to use a reusable component
those things always come uh
with with you know talking to customers
understanding their challenges
because they always ask one feature you
talk to them you understand what the
challenge is
and then you say hey here's another
feature which is much better so orin
talk to me a little bit about this
feedback cycle this agile methodology
that you're using
of of developing a product watching your
users talking to them understanding the
pain points obviously as somebody who's
been doing it for years
as an engineer yourself you can
sympathize very very well with with
these
pain points how do you then translate
that into a product that doesn't yet
exist
right because you're developing products
that don't yet exist you're taking pain
points that do exist
and you're creatively finding solutions
for them through test mio so how does
that process look like
um i i think in my case it it helps that
have been in this domain for a long time
right and first of all i there was a
company that was willing to pay even
before
we had the product wow that was i think
about 60 000
contract and i showed them sketches so
i think they trusted me because they saw
earlier when i worked it out
in april's they saw me building a
product from
from idea to a real
real product and i think they trusted so
that's you need to build that
that trust with the community um
but but i think it's it's working very
closely
with with the customers from day zero
and ongoing all the time working with
them
you have one thing and that's in the
beginning of a call let's just say
someone's paying you already
you have one thing that you have to ask
them in the beginning what are your
goals
what are your goals and how can i make
you
the happiest person in the universe and
and then you start thinking okay let's
do this
by the way the trick here the trick here
is that sometimes
um a person's goals and the company
goals
they don't necessarily all the time
online i think
i think it's very important uh when
you're building a product it's also
uh you need to start understanding
how do people how do they think what
makes them happy
and where do they want to be and it's
funny because it's like
everyone asked uh where do you want to
be in five years you have to know that
right in in a 30 minute conversation and
to
understand that with that person where
do they want to go and make them happy
so there's two things you said we were
talking about sell
the only thing is trying to understand
what people want as the as the
individual
second thing is what makes the company
or the manager
what would that make the manager happy i
love that
or and where where do you see this going
in five ten years the industry not
necessarily just testimo but but this
idea of
of of tests of tests first and test
driven mentality
what what what where do you see us going
in 10 15 years in terms of development
um first of all i think you developers
there's always talking about the shift
left that developers do testing earlier
i think developers will also shift right
developers will be much more connected
to what's going on in production
all the time when they see something
when something
something doesn't doesn't work i think
that everything that's going on in
production you'll understand first of
all what are your users doing
right now when someone's writing tests
they don't even know what's going on in
production
that's crazy they don't know what what
are the users we're usually doing
imagine that you would that you do know
what all your users are doing
what are the things that you didn't do
if something a bug happened that you
know exactly what the scenario is
automatically so i think those are but
that's
you only 10 20 years for that that would
be
that's going to be much sooner i think
uh after that i think there will be
um you will connect more the product
level
i think you'll be able to test more or
define what the scenarios
when you're talking about the product
this is what i want the product to be
okay here's my test automatically
generated
right those would have to come i love
but it's uh
yeah we i think it has to come it has to
it will be there don't worry i i love
that and uh
and i had the pleasure of both
developing with testing and without
testing
and i can definitely testify that it's
it's a different world
and when building the application there
and the number of times that i found
myself
breaking my head against the wall when i
didn't do test driven development
it was it was awful so to all my friends
at stanford every 200
they're listening to this i'm a huge
believer both intestine and
testimony oh and thank you for
introducing me to this world
a lot of it is due to the work that
you're doing with testament io that i
got involved more and more
and learn about it so thank you for that
but oren before we before we finish
i need to ask you for the most important
question which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
and i know that and i apologize in
advance that i did not i did not
tell you enough time in advance so i'm
not gonna hold you accountable to them
um do you have do you have to describe
myself in three words
however you'd like to answer the
question yeah so i'm
first of all i think like a lot of
entrepreneurs i am i'm a person
that loves learning i love and and i
think
uh i'm doing what i enjoy myself the
most which is
i'm learning every day even years even
in the same company you keep learning it
all the time so i love that
and but things that i think the people
don't know about me
is that on one hand i play the guitar
you always always play
uh please dielectric guitar
and on the other hand uh i love rock and
on the other hand
uh i play chase chess now every day
actually not
just regular it's bug house it's a
chess variation uh two people versus two
people
so it's a little bit more you have to
look at two boards
and it's this is uh this this is the
nice part when it's more
it's of course you have to think about
you know uh
10 moves ahead and of course there's
another world but there's also
communication with other people
so i think um so i think and i see
you like that as well i can see that uh
it's not just about technology and ideas
and about cracking the
the optimal just uh solution how to win
your opponent
you need you have a partner and you need
to talk to them and tell them what you
need
and you need them to help you out and
you help them which is i think this is
this is uh uh what i love uh
what i love most in is that working with
people and having that
building that all together and the next
thing i'm gonna do right about this is
two things is first invite you to a game
on chess.com and the next one is looking
up this two versus two game
and because it looks wonderful oren
thank you very much to raghavan this was
this was just wonderful thank you ah
you're welcome my friend
take care